This strong and oral form of 5FU was used in chemo and radiotherapy and also could be considered
as a replacement for 5B 5FU. It has side effects though, this includes hand foot syndrome.
Hand foot syndrome is a syndrome that's very common with chemo therapy patients. And it's because of what I just discussed a second ago.
It's because these things are very toxic to neurons. The hand foot syndrome, you can get these weird symptoms in your hands or your feet, in your extremities to stop specific to your hands and feet, but it's in your in your further extremities.
And because it's a strong toxin, and so the question is, are you aware of natural options, perhaps polyopathy to reduce the side effects of this oral chemo in general or for hand foot syndrome.
So, I think that your best option is to be doing the bioprolym because you can do that on your hands, you can do that on your feet, and it will help pull that out.
The negative about doing that, is that that program can take like 45 minutes and it's kind of a pain to do.
So, that would be the downside, using some toxic keylators would be your next best thing.
But you do have to be aware of the 7 phases of detoxification here and make sure that you are.
Your body is ready to do phase zero of detoxification, which is using a key later to grab onto things to pull out of your body.
You also have to be aware that you can't really do any heavy key laders.
If you have metal in your body, we need let's say you have a platinum plate from a fracture back when you were at high school can't really do that or a nickel plate.
You can't do heavy key laders if you still have mercury fillings the silver fillings.
So if you have metal in your body that way, you have metal in your body like a pacemaker, you're fine, because it's encased in plaques at plastic and such.
So, but metal in your body that you could end up chelating could be a problem.
You don't have don't fall into any of those categories, then think about doing some.
Heavy or like chelation type therapies.
It's just supporting the glutathione pathways can be helpful as well. So using that liquid liposomal glutathione can be very beneficial.
Nutrients that will help stimulate glutathione alpha-repair acid and fly seed and some other things like that that help you grow the bio recycling process can be helpful.
Also, we need foods that support that pathway like onions, garlic can be helpful for that.
So glutathione is your made intracellular detoxifier but adding a key later helps grab onto it in the blood so it doesn't get to positive somewhere else.
So, if you don't have metal in your body, you feel like you've been addressing other detoxification pathways, which this person who asked this question has.
Think of things like our if you're talking about a key later that I'm talking about a heavy key later is our product called with some colors, but a product called key and clear.
So, if you do have metal in your body and that is an issue, then you have to you have to use key the clearest also cause we renamed it.
It's called phase zero.
And then we have another product that is designs for health, metal like synergy.
And that is really probably what that is to think it is on backward right now.
But that product is our private label, phase zero insists because it's a little bit milder of a key later.
And then that key la clearest key la clearest a stronger key later.
So, those are two products that you can think of and that can be good.
Also think about using binders in the gut to you to explain all those things in the same basic detox course to explore that.